in der engadiner bergwelt liegt das
hochalpine institut fan
hier lernen und wohnen schüler von nah
und fern
zeva auf sankt petersburg befindet sich
im letzten jahr des gymnasiums
schulkollegen batliner wohnt in school
und besucht die sportklasse
auch für robin aus der innerschweiz
stellen sich nun die weichen fürs leben
ein team von internetbetrügern kümmert
sich um die freuden und sorgen der
jugendlichen
und gerhard steuble amt als rektor des
traditionsreichen instituts für alle ist
es das jahr der entscheidungen
[Musik]
nervosität bei rektor gerhard steuble
an einem montagmorgen im februar
versammeln sich sämtliche schüler im
speisesaal des hochalpinen instituts
sie warten auf eine mitteilung des
rektors bereits machten gerüchte die
runde
[Musik]
schon in der letzten folge der
internatsschule fan war die lage
angespannt gerhard steuble versuchte die
lehrerschaft zu beruhigen schu kritische
artikel hatten sie in aufregung versetzt
sorgen auch bei abschluss christa
schäfer puschkin seine maturaarbeit
konnte er zwar noch rechtzeitig
fertigstellen doch prorektor pleite
machte ihm klar dass er vor größeren
problemen steht
[Musik]
informationsbedarf und die
verwaltungsratssitzung nach den
kritischen presseberichten wurde zur
schicksalsstunde für gerhard steuble
während einer autofahrt wurde der rektor
über die beschlüsse informiert in der
folge traf steuble eine entscheidung von
großer tragweite
[Musik]
der bisher für aufmerksamkeit bieten
es ist mir ein großes anliegen dass hier
jetzt offiziell und durch mich selber
orientiert werden die situation ist so
dass der verwaltungsrat auf das ende des
schuljahres hat den beiden prorektoren
frau weiskopf und der leitl gekündigt
und dies alles hat mich dazu bewogen
jetzt ebenfalls aufzuhören auf ende
dieses schuljahres ich habe am freitag
den rücktritt als rektor erklärt
gut das war schon die ganze sensation
wir werden aber bis in den sommerferien
noch hier sein rechnet mit uns wir
werden immer noch die gleiche linie
durchziehen wie es im sommer und dann
auch wird dann vielleicht eine neue ära
beginnen also herzlichen dank an dem
buch
applaus vermutlich geboren aus
hilflosigkeit
[Applaus]
wieder
[Musik]
unsere familie ist schon ziemlich krass
dass jetzt bleibt die ganze schule
leitungswasser das die forscher damit
gerechnet dass
regen dahin sich dass irgendeine andere
lehrer der schule oder das kloster
spanish flea jetzt extrem
[Musik]
profi nur dass sie
verfügen das für die elite
[Musik]
ich glaube auf touren gekommen jetzt
das
unaufgeregte euro pro jahr
was nicht kommuniziert wird sind die
gründe weshalb die prorektoren entlassen
worden der verwaltungsrat will sich dazu
nicht äußern was sich sagen lässt die
entlassung von stoll place engsten
mitarbeitern ist als reaktion zu sehen
auf die kritischen zeitungsartikel darin
erhobenen ehemalige lehrer schwere
vorwürfe wie den der noten manipulation
die vorwürfe gewesen hatte nach wie vor
extrem zurück
oder schafft und prorektor hat
unmittelbare dem alltagsgeschäft america
to be seen wo vom verwaltungsrat und
klare worte sehr interessanten schärfe
boten unter der fürsorge und
das hat dann habe jeder sehr viele
eigentlich mit mir einverstanden ist
wofür ich und frauen tot ist aber
niemand einfach daran nicht richtig
vorstellen dass das thema vor ort
miteinander unterwegs ist nachher die
beide
schulleitung mitglied werden und das
recht beliebt wie drinnen im saal setzte
das ist für mich
von meinen gedanken chef ist das
periodische fort
hast du als du am nachmittag nation von
halb drei beck
die entscheidung als rektor
zurückzutreten ist schwer gefallen in
schlaflosen nächten hat er sich
schließlich zu dem entschluss
durchgerungen und dies obwohl ihm der
verwaltungsrat das volle vertrauen
ausgesprochen hatte
der schulbetrieb muss trotz rücktritt
weitergehen das wechselspiel von
systemen
center wird raab mit
[Musik]
mathematiklehrer schäuble gibt eine
korrigierte prüfungsarbeit an die
schüler zurück
[Musik]
die wochen ins land
nach einem langen winter beginnt die
natur sich zaghaft zu erholen und von
neuem zu erblühen
genauso muss auch das hochalpine
institut nach den querelen rund um die
schulleitung wie der frische kraft
schöpfen
[Musik]
in der aula des instituts findet eine
große tagung statt zur neuausrichtung
der schule
verwaltungsratspräsident professor
doktor rolf dubs hat alle lehrer
internats mitarbeiter und einzelne
schüler eingeladen nur die neue
schulleitung fehlt noch die suche nach
ihr läuft auf hochtouren
referierte damen und herren es freut
mich sehr sie aber arbeits nach rechts
begrüßen was die meisten wahrscheinlich
interessiert ist frau sechs mitbewerber
bezüglich schulleitung sind bis jetzt
fix fertige prof 14 bewerbungen und es
hatte unter deiner bewerber hervorragend
die bewerbung
muss kein problem löse dürften das
könnten stattfinden
nun also das ziel lüttich das normal
versichert über das profil
jede krise bietet auch chancen bei der
anstehenden diskussion über das profil
der internatsschule fan versucht der
verwaltungsrat möglichst viele
mitarbeiter und sonstwie beteiligte
einzubinden
mit dem ziel vertrauen zu schaffen und
kräfte zu einem
fein wenn nichts mehr ist dann darf ich
sie bitten sich jetzt zu den gruppen zu
begegnen sie haben die liste mit den
raum angaben wir haben sorgfältig
gewicht damit alle meinungen
hineinkommen ich wünsche ihnen eine gute
arbeit ist 12 uhr 30
in gruppen sollen nun die stärken und
schwächen des hochalpinen instituts
analysiert werden
die alte schulleitung nimmt an der
tagung nicht teil
rektor gerhard stäbler und sein
langjähriger vorgesetzter professor
doktor rolf dubs gehen bald getrennte
wege
wir haben
hart steuble seinerseits verlässt das
institut mit einem weinenden auge
während gleich neben seinem büro die
neuausrichtung der schule diskutiert
wird kümmert er sich weiter um das
tagesgeschäft
zeigen ist das halb - und
somit erheblich weiß dass ich für
schulen zu machen sondern es ist also
ein findiger damit ausdruck gegenüber
dem ganzen da und waren das jetzt
plötzlich wegfällt
dann tut mir das leid und das tut
ja persönlich betroffen machen das ist
überhaupt nicht das ziel sein das ziel
ist sie bei einem idealpass behandlungen
nicht nur für den rektor stehen die
letzten wochen am institut an sondern
auch für abschlussklasse robin peking er
präsentiert ergebnisse aus der
gruppenarbeit
klinik wasser das gehört alles zusammen
ist in der schule mit knapp 200 schüler
im internationalen
und da haben wir viel besser auf die
individuellen bedürfnisse gar als jetzt
zum beispiel eine öffentliche schule
profunder bis 26 jahre sind und diesmal
aus schülern oder hier ist mir hier ist
man hier bin ich froh bin hier bin ich
der optik
rathenow und chris aber ich bin nicht so
persönlich mit mit mit der schulleitung
italiener und ja dass wir schlecht sagen
robbins vorschläge sollen ebenso wie die
ideen aus den anderen gruppen weiter
diskutiert und verdichtet werden eine
projektgruppe wurde hierfür eingesetzt
zu einem neuen schulprofil ist es jedoch
noch ein weiter weg
nach der tagung kehrt ruhe ein am
institut
robin kann mit seinem freund clemens
wieder alltäglichen bedürfnissen
nachgehen
die beiden fahren los um essen
einzukaufen 7 ich viel essen nicht für
sich sondern für ihre mitbewohner im
internat
gegen abend
ja ist halt eine sehr hohe nachfrage
nach essen ja und dann sind wir
eigentlich auf die sehr gut die idee
gekommen die könnten doch
produkte verkaufen sowie alina leider
mache erst einen kleinen kiosk einfach
zum anfang ist so
solide vertraut der kunde habe mir
danach gefragt als das ist mir einfach
sagte kvist und dem internet vielleicht
sich alles sie möchten eine lunge und
dann sind plötzlich
und
eigentlich aber hungrig automatisch so
wie es
dabei gibt es täglich sechs mahlzeiten
am internat vom frühstück über das
mittagessen bis zum späten aber es
werden natürlich keine chips
schokoriegel oder süßigkeiten
aufgetischt
internatsleiterin ruth berlau hat die
aufsicht über den schiri übernommen
seit vier jahren arbeitet sie fast 100
prozent im internet jetzt nach der
großen tagung verspürt sie neue energie
arena hat sich der federführenden
projektgruppe angeschlossen
eine dame betrifft das für eine frau
fand die plätze foto dies kopiert oder
reflektieren
[Musik]
im vierten stock wo die ältesten wohnen
sind die große einkäufer in sachen
junkfood zurück
sie haben sich im nahen österreich mit
produkten eingedeckt je günstiger die
waren umso größer die marge
so dass jetzt da lied das ich für
schätzungsweise zwei wochen langen das
würde ich mal sagen grob geschätzt
zentraler bestandteil von robins
geschäftsmodell ist auch dass er ein
eigenes auto hat fast als einziger im
internet die anderen müssen zu fuß oder
mit dem bus einkaufen gehen und das ist
den meisten zu mühsam
robin und sein freund clemens verteilen
die es waren in ihrer beiden zimmer
nicht zuletzt aus sicherheitsgründen
aber
sich nicht krank und wurde und sich also
viel dem xi und sich
mit release weil das rasch als zweites
mittragen in dem bereich mit seiner
mannschaft und schickte andere sachen
zurück das
ccf stets magna
zwei zimmer weiter ist robbins
klassenkollege siva puschkin in
bedrückter stimmung seit vier jahren
besucht der russe nun die
internatsschule getan doch ein so
schlechtes zeugnis wie sein letztes
hatte er noch nie seine eltern die pro
jahr 45.000 franken für das internat
bezahlen sind informiert über die
ungenügende leistungen ihres sohnes
ja schlecht
ja sozusagen nicht zufrieden
es sind nur noch wenige wochen bis zu
den maturaprüfungen und silber hat sich
einen gehörigen rückstand eingehandelt
[Musik]
jüngere wurden werden im vierten stock
eigentlich nicht gerne gesehen außer sie
haben gute geschäftsbeziehungen
[Musik]
wenn ich die beliebte und kaufen die
beliebten guppys die alleinige leider
nicht ja aber die
sind ja so wird man nicht wortlos nahm
weil sie zum strand da kein können
am ende ja sehr viel leichter das design
kannst
du mir mal das auto putzen
nein
internat mitarbeiterin ruth per jänner
ist für die heutige nachtschicht
eingeteilt zu später stunde ist sie mit
den jugendlichen alleine im institut
im dom klettern also das sei falsch
genau zugleich vital so ganz bequem
weiß nicht was passiert war der
medihoney wirklichen überblick
die mediothek kurz medio liegt im
mädchen trakt bei jeder hat so eine
leise ahnung dass in dieser nacht ein
paar der jungs herüber schleichen
könnten
[Musik]
es nach das dach der apple bewegt
warum einfach doch hof
[Musik]
im mädchen trakt gibt es je ein
treppenhaus auf beiden seiten
wäre versucht den unerlaubten besuch zu
finden sie weiß welche mädchen eher in
frage kommen für nächtliche
männergesellschaft
[Musik]
wahrscheinlich ist dass zehn berliner
beispiel mit renault sa die vermutung
von biella während sie das eine
treppenhaus hochstieg flüchtete der
junge über das treppenhaus auf der
anderen seite
soll es wenigstens ting wir sind mir zu
schlafen
[Musik]
was machst du da ein junge fragt nach
schmerztabletten
gut ich komme jetzt mach mit
[Musik]
bei jeder vermutet zwar dass der junge
vorgeschickt wurde um sie abzulenken
trotzdem muss seine bitte ernst nehmen
denn womöglich hat er tatsächlich
schmerzen
kaum ist ballack muss jemand die treppe
hoch zu den mädchen zimmer
[Musik]
kurt leite begibt sich in den vierten
stock
im internetbereich ist der projektor
kaum je anzutreffen denn er ist
ausschließlich für schulische belange
zuständig
leitl begibt sich zum thema von sefa
puschkin
13 uhr 20 im büro von rektor
euro
ich
bin deine noten
nimm dein handy mit höchsten eltern
er sollte eigentlich in der mathematik
stunde der 6g sitzen robin ist anwesend
ebenso mal einer
sie sitzt im langlauf stress hinter der
schulbank
das hat seinen grund
nach der stunde erwartet ein ganz
besonderes langlauftraining auf sieg
geleitet wird es von doppel
olympiasieger dario cologna
die knapp 20 jährige beeilt sich
möglichst schnell wie sie zum training
[Musik]
ein paar hundert meter weiter unten in
schaan sämtlicher schnee wurde hier zu
einer kleinen langlaufloipe
zusammengekratzt denn der könig der
langläufer macht seine aufwartung dario
cologna er ist ohne skier hier während
sein bruder gianluca aktiv mit
trainieren wird
beide haben sie im internat des
hochalpinen instituts gewohnt und in der
sportklasse den grundstein für ihre
karrieren gelegt
es ist ein treffen unter freunden
weiter mit als normaler nur wärme runde
machte zwei minuten land sieht und
denselben grad bestimmen und werden eine
noch ein anderer hof für
dario cologna kennt das gelände hier mit
jeder seiner unebenheiten unzählige
langlauf runden hatten absolviert
[Applaus]
batliner kommt ein wenig später als die
anderen ins training der matheunterricht
war ihr wichtiger
das ist mal einer kadenz
batliner hat schon einige goldmedaillen
geholt an den schweizer meisterschaften
im schwimmen
sie ist in der klasse die dieses jahr ab
schießt
das gymnasium
wir wärmen uns zuerst ein wenig auf dann
starten wir von dort hinten und fahnen
hoch bis zu dieser blauen fahne da wo es
um die kurve geht
ein kleiner wettkampf ist geplant ein
sogenanntes doppelstock rennen bei dem
man sich nur mit den armen abstoßen darf
ohne die beine zu benutzen in dieser
disziplin kann man leider trotz ihrer
behinderung problemlos mithalten
[Musik]
dario cologna beobachtet man kleiner
aufmerksam
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja und die mannschaft zum glück war ist
der ostermarsch aurubis
habe ich doch skoda
bei den männern läuft auch colognas
bruder gianluca mit
dario cologna selber kann nicht mittun
seien für olympia eilig zusammen
gepflegtes sprunggelenk schmerzt ihn
wieder aber hauptsache der fuß hat für
zwei goldmedaillen gehalten
[Musik]
wie ein gewinner dürfte sich abschluss
pflaster seeber puschkin kaum fühlen
im büro des rektors wartet die
schulleitung auf ihr thema sein
schlechtes zeugnis
[Musik]
schäfer weiß dass er nicht viel gutes
von dieser sitzung erwarten darf
er war stehen notebooks
[Musik]
ganzen buch über 1 7 gegen den halter
notendurchschnitt
zur minuspunkt nicht weiß dass ich jetzt
höllisch ist es mit distanzierter vor
den österreicher zeigen das ist das
notenbild wohl nicht danke tarifsystem
immer wohl da kann man eigentlich
nur noch mit widerstand wer eigentlich
weiß dass man die fäden einfachen auch
komplett und kommen das weiß als die
lebenssituation stellte man jetzt sehr
konzerttagen verletzt selber für mich
wo es mir ein erfahrung für andere jahr
mit allen schülern das ist repetition
weil aus den noten
dürfte
kommendes romandie april als zweiter
zeugnis und jeden zweiten zeugnis
ausstellen - bankkunden so viel
unterwegs aber
dann war sie selber schenken und darin
dann könnte kilometer hälfte 14 macht
sie zuerst nur jugend an die jugend soll
das jammertal sich also die jugend seine
cc automation blogs und osttirol ist und
wo es für die abstimmung hat und dass
der täter keine grundlage malta aktions
entwickelt fühlen und maler
unbeschwerter skifahren und einmal
unbeschwert mit anderen zusammen zählt
der stadt permanent unter druck
wenn du angst vor den eltern regeln
etwas
aber sonst so unterstützen wir dich und
auch das gespräch mit den eltern wird
sicher so sein dass wir es positiv in
die zukunft begleiten wollen und dass
wir und ich glauben und dass du diese
matura schafft
lassen wir uns mal mein parteien
kommst du auf uns zu bitten weil du
weißt wenn du soweit ist
[Musik]
schäfer steht vor einer schwierigen
entscheidung und keine der perspektiven
klingt verlockend
also ich danke auch an bord besser store
außen von repetition überzeugen und
weitere fröhliche junge zauberer
möglichkeit sich nach
stand der dinge und unrealistische
betracht
dario cologna ist mit seinem bruder zum
hochalpinen institut hochgekommen
ihrem einstigen zu hause wo acht jahren
hat cologna hier das gymnasium
abgeschlossen
einer der damals bereits im institut
arbeitete ist der küchenchef emiliana
damiani
er scheint sich auf die rückkehr des
bekanntesten absolventen der schule zu
freuen
als der herr ins internat kam kam er mir
bis hier hin nun ist es so groß
am anfang war er alles andere als ein
heiliger später dass sich sehr geändert
habe am anfang
dario cologna hat in den letzten jahren
das institut nur sehr selten besucht
umso größer die freude bei den
gastgebern
dario wie geht's gut gut und hier auch
gut
[Musik]
für den weltklasse sportler ist es auch
eine rückkehr im kulinarischen sinne
groß und stark scheint ihm das essen
jedenfalls gemacht zu haben
vier jahre lang hat cologna fast täglich
in diesem speisesaal gegessen
am heutigen tag verpflegt sich auch
robin pps wie ein olympiasieger
den jüngeren der beiden colonia brüder
kennt gerhard steuble persönlich aus
seiner amtszeit als
dario cologna die schule besucht er war
er allerdings noch nicht rektor am
institut
es war schön wenn er nachrufe haben die
geldstrafe seines
erachtens marke drum vierter stock und
und waren jetzt nur interessant
hält
einer der heutigen bewohner des vierten
stocks versucht sich abzulenken
screenshot die simpsons auf russisch
er muss sich entscheiden ob er auf den
vorschlag des rektors eingehen und der
sechste schuljahr repetieren soll
schweigend lässt er die angelegenheit
sich erst einmal setzen
[Musik]
robbins wunsch geht in erfüllung dario
cologna besucht im vierten stock jenes
zimmer das er zuletzt bewohnte
vorbei an der tür von sefa geht eher in
die richtung von robins bleibe
zwei dann aber ab in das zimmer
gegenüber dort wo robbins freund clemens
wohnt
wollte sie und nicht immer einfach und
sportler
im internat und ja damals schon bisher
die disziplin hat zum 15 auch
von team ico und ist nicht mit dem rad
sie aber
wichtige frage
noch einmal fertig ist
ich bin natürlich viel unterwegs sehen
ja
dass keine hände mehr übrigen gefasst
dass man alles machen
wir das wenn man freude für das volk die
macht
wegen dieser sache
rangehen der maturant robin pittis und
der olympiasieger dario cologna
was die beiden verbindet ist ihre
schulzeit am hochalpinen institut sie
teilen die erinnerungen an einen ort an
dem ein prägendes kapitel ihres lebens
geschrieben wurde hier drückten sie
zahllose stunden die schulbank wie
hunderte anderer schüler ein
lebensabschnitt der sein ende nach
eifrigem lernen in den
abschlussprüfungen findet
[Musik]
doch einige werden mit gemischten
gefühlen auf ihre zeit am bieneninstitut
zurückblicken
selber puschkin hat sich entschieden das
internat zu verlassen und nach russland
zurück zu kehren
[Applaus]
[Musik]
den schick nein nicht
ich habe mich schon dass ich zum einen
kommen
dpa einfach ich aber auch nichts dafür
bekommt sozusagen ja ich habe schon
tipps bekommen aber ich meine es
bringt ein weiteres label nichts
gemeinsam mit den eltern hat sich selber
gegen eine repetition des sechsten
schuljahres entschieden
vielleicht nächstes jahr aber
haben wir das ganz schön sein aber
wenn wir zum beispiel nächstes jahr
nicht schaffen
sie war verlässt unvermittelt seine
zweite heimat seine schulklasse und
seine freunde wie konnte es nur so weit
kommen
ich denke der nachricht
ich bin schon
unzufrieden mit mir ein bisschen dass
sich meine eltern
durch und durch tafeln und
wir müssen irgendwie weitermachen
[Musik]
der flug nach sankt petersburg wartet
in der nächsten und letzten folge der
internatsschule geht es los mit den
prüfungen dafür sogar ob ihn erwischt
[Musik]
nach den schriftlichen prüfungen warten
auf die maturanten noch die mündlichen
tests
2000 kilometer entfernt in sankt
petersburg
[Applaus]
puschkin feiert mit seinen russischen
freunden den alten schulkollegen drückt
er die daumen
ich hoffe dass wir das alles schaffen
rektor gerhard steuble zeigt seinen
nachfolger das hochalpine institut
und am ende brennen die schulbücher
[Musik]